We have a big epidemic with police officers
and deputies shooting dogs.
I mean I would bet you that 95% of law enforcement
on the street today
have never received this kind of training
or information, they do not have it.
You know, I come from the old school where
I started my police career back in the early 70s
and back then I was taught to us to neutralize
a dog.
Dogs were just considered property.
And in society today it's changed and dogs
are not just property, they're part of the family
and unfortunately our profession hasn't caught
up to that yet
and so that's why we're working really hard
to try to get this training
so officers now can have it and know what's
going on.
Because when an officer ends up shooting a dog
it really rips right at the fabric of the community.
All you have to do is google 'police shoots
dog' or 'deputy shoots dog'
there's a website called Puppycide that's
documenting every shooting
that's putting every one on page.
This problem needs to be solved.
So we talked to VirTra, which is one of the
manufacturers of the virtual training
and said 'would you be willing to work with
us on this?'
'would you be willing to take the time to
add these scenarios
to your already, you know, already good library
of situations that law enforcement handles.'
And they were very receptive of it.
-report of a subject down, possible medical
condition.
Get on doggie, get, sir, sir are you okay?
I could sit in a class and talk to you and
tell you how dogs behave
and I can show you some videos
but when you can step in this 360 environment
and you see a dog coming at you
and depending on how you act is how the scenario
is going to go
there's nothing that you can do any better
than that.
Have you seen my dog? a black-
He ran around that way.
He ran off that way.
Hey, hey dog stay!
Can you control your dog then?
We need to make sure that officers understand
dog behavior
because if you understand the way that dog
behaves, the chances of you shooting are slim to none.
Alright, sir we need your dog to calm down.
What are you doing?
I said he doesn't bite, he's not dangerous!
You can't wait until after an incident happens
and then everybody rushes out to get the training
because the damage is done.
And that's why we took on this challenge
because we realized that law enforcement didn't
get it.
So if we can teach officers dog behavior
and things that are gonna help them when they
get in these encounters
it makes them and everyone else safe
and it keeps the life of a pet in that family
where it belongs.